thank you yasser we are indeed with
linear dominguez after a tremendous
victory against the number one favorite
levon aronian linear first of all big
congratulations a win with the black
pieces against such a strong opponent
did he surprise you in the opening with
this move e4 and how did you approach
this game yeah thank you um well i
it wasn't really a surprise i mean 11
plays both e4 and d4 so
i
i wasn't really surprised by his by his
choice but i do think that he played the
opening uh
in a dubious way
and uh
after the move bishop b5 bishop d7 it it
it feels that black is somehow already
better because all my pieces are coming
to the center with tempo and
and then uh it it it looks very ugly for
for white from from that point maybe
it's it's uh not lost but
certainly a very nice position just
right from the opening perhaps we can
see that a position on the board right
now we were surprised by this move
bishop to b5 as well also we were
surprised that he was playing so fast
did you guys discuss the opening at all
after the game did he tell you where he
missed his preparation yeah i think he
uh probably confused the lines and he
thought that
because he was thinking about the lines
where black plays c6 first and then goes
c5 and then we get some very similar
positions and and then i think he
thought that he was just the temple down
or something like that and that's why he
went bishop bishop b5 but
uh i mean after a move like bishop b5
it's clear that something went uh
seriously wrong for white i think g4 is
the move that is consistent with what
white is doing but then c4 yeah and
bishop f1 i wasn't sure bishop b2 allows
bishop d6 maybe and there are some i
mean the pieces on the file are a bit uh
yeah 27 ideas or yeah we should d4 and
then i thought maybe
maybe i can take on g5 hd and quincy
sound this is an idea
you
you checkmated him on the dark squares
in this case he might he might return
the favor on on the dark squares as well
uh
something terrible
nothing
happy
ah there is a rookie five right
yes
[Laughter]
was also the question for us we we were
surprised by right it seemed that it
helped you i think if something like uh
like g4 has to be played and then c4 and
i don't know if bgb2 or bishop f1 but
essentially i will for example after a
month like bishop f1
i will go b5 or queen a5 and b5 maybe b5
first it's more flexible
and then
with the bishop on f1 it's not the same
white attack because uh
i can i mean it's a bit slow still and
this knight xf7 king f7 g5 it's probably
not working because of knight h5 and
sorry to interrupt you guys we do have a
result as we expected alice lee has
defeated tatev abrahamian very good to
take a 1-0 lead in the classical and uh
you were saying at this point knight h5
you're seeing these types of variations
you were expecting
this type of game i was expecting
something like this yes crazy so after
bishop b5 however
suddenly you thought how well sweet it
is i mean everything comes to the center
as you said is he free play
yeah it look just looks very very nice
for black i was i wasn't sure if it was
um i mean
uh close to winnie or something but uh
but it was certainly
very pleasant and here i saw this yeah
this uh bomb sacrifice which i think
it's good because practically it's very
hard for white to
to play this position especially because
i get c3
um the point is that c3 of course allows
queen f5 check and and then rook takes
e3 did the move g3 come as a surprise
for you um i was it on your race yeah i
thought that white has to try to do
something on the queen side and
and try to protect i don't know
i was thinking bishop d2 or
or king a1 those were the moves i was
mostly considering right g3 for me was
just like completely
not yeah it feels that black is very
close to to a win here right and i don't
know if what i play is correct but uh
we felt that uh this was his last moment
yeah
bishop c1 probably has to be played yeah
and the the computer was showing some
crazy
way that white may it stays in the game
but it's very very
yeah we were discussing some line uh
after the game something like bishop c1
but i'm i'm not sure if it's correct and
if white takes on e1 i mean if black
takes only one rookie one yes
uh rook a6 yes then there is uh
queen d3 apparently exactly if bishop c1
king c1 and you try to run for the king
runs and uh yeah and if bishop b2
instead of bishop takes c1
yep then a4
sorry interrupt but we also have another
result in the championship bracket
asparagus
and sam savion do draw their game as we
expected only one game left there sorry
guys not at all after a4 yeah
yeah there is just a um
you might still bring the line
queen before now it looks good yes uh
because queen a3 is a huge threat so
bishop takes b2
uh cb2 and c3 queen b3 wins but here
instead of bishop takes b2 white has
uh knight d5 oh
that's queen a3 yes
knight takes of six gf6 rookie eight k7
bishop takes h6 and white wins
oh it's gonna
but on the other side
oh my god
that's the cold shower that's pretty sad
oh that's very sad but you have seen
this no i mean we were just moving the
pieces after the game but uh nice what a
move knight d5
yeah but uh probably black has to play
rook a6 uh immediately instead of taking
on e1 and this way after rookie 898
maybe then put the knight on d6 i mean i
have no idea but essentially this bishop
c1 i think was probably the the last
chance the last chance you know
congratulations lanier uh thank you the
american cup
welcome welcome
nice
yeah very smooth victory there
congratulations lanier that was a great
game
wow just
smooth with black against levon